la portée du hashtag pierre qui quitté
en tête arrière
vous comprenez parce que honnêtement
pour vous aussi de se dire que cette
réflexion que cette dame voilée
c'était quelque part un peu une
manipulation de macron pour essayer d'en
faire parler vous y croyez ou pasteur il
serait plus à gauche à droite moi je n'y
crois pas d'accord je pense qu'elle a
avec sincérité pu exprimer sa réalité
quotidienne
c est ce que c'est par votre
dévalorisant autre question se pose la
question de se dire quand même c'est
quand même curieux qui est un garçon de
8 ans demande à sa mère est ce que le
prénom pire existe et c'est pas normal
on a bu du whisky vie parce que hilda il
a un portable et la télévision il à
internet on peut quand même pas être ça
excusez moi mais c'est un peu c'est pas
un peu too much
moi je pense que c'est une réalité quand
je pense que c'est une réalité après je
peux me tromper
tous les gens comme enfin je veux dire
moi je suis quand même ici de
l'immigration mazet une mère est
algérienne j'ai un père qui est français
quand j'écoutais les deux hier soir mais
je me mets ou moi shu
je comprends que les gens se unis dans
les cités mais je pense qu'ils sont unis
par la misère y parce que c'est du vrai
il ya de l'entr'aide mais on n'a pas pas
la couleur de pondre mais moi je suis
quand même je crains des migrations 8 6
je suis me sont totalement français et
j'ai la chance d'habiter en france et ça
m'attriste en fait de voir ce débat
encore en 2021 cetc c'est insensé et que
vous avez été élevé rend en banlieue ou
non j'ai vécu dans un hlm mais d'un
appartement en banlieue mais bon mais
est ce que l époque cette question je se
posait escource d'ethias et il ya plus
de 6 plus de ça non non non parce qu'on
regardait pas la couleur de peau
encore une fois on était unie par la
misère et moi on s'entraînait avec le
peu qu'on avait moi j'ai des voisins car
il se savait y avait des étés je n'avais
pas d'électricité et on bouffait d'être
du pain enfin du pain quand la
boulangère approuvée nulle quand il
restait du pain la boulangère nous
donner du pain
et que le matin faute réveillé pour
aller à l'école en avait pas
d'électricité c'était la voisine qui
nous achetaient des piles pour maître
dans l'art de réveil pour travailler
pour aller à l'école le matin et oui on
était solidaires votre dans cette misère
mais pas rien à voir avec la couleur de
peau
c'est ce débat je trouve qu'il m'a fait
réfléchir moi franchement j'y ai pensé
énormément après c'est un vrai débat
pour réfléchir et pourrait améliorer les
choses et de bonnes questions j'ai
d'accord est d'accord